un invité surprise aujourd'hui puisqu'il
s'agit du grand maître international
champion de france en 1992 manuel a
pissé la douce - bonsoir manuel donc
l'actualité cette semaine mais tout
d'abord première chose à annoncer pour
demain c'est un match sur internet
contre judit polgar la meilleure joueuse
du monde et diagonales a le plaisir de
vous annoncer que nous offrons cinq
places pour jouer demain sur goa
www.geocaching.com vous nous envoyez un
mail et en retour nous donnerons à user
password pour jouer contre judit polgar
la meilleure joueuse du monde donc qu'il
voit c'est quand même une occasion de
pas manquer ouais tout à fait oui ça
fait enfin je n'ai pas le souvenir que
j'ai dit que le gars soit venue en
france
personnellement donc c'est vrai que
c'est l'occasion de jouer la meilleure
joueuse du monde elle valait donc à ce
fameux marathon de valence les 30 heure
de valence où les joueurs sont invités
donc à jouer soit en équipe soit tout
seul pendant 30 heures d'affilée donc ça
va être un événement intéressant j'ai
des pallières va y participer donc c'est
l'occasion pour vous internautes de
jouer pour la meilleure joueuse du monde
voilà donc vous cliquez sur contact vous
nous envoyez un petit mail vous dites
que vous êtes intéressé vous nous donnez
votre niveau et l'eau au classement elo
et nous sélectionnerons les cinq
meilleurs joueurs pour jouer demain donc
à 17 heures contre judit polgar 17
heures heure française évidemment la
simultanée ouverte aux québécois aux
américains à tous ceux qui nous
regardent de par le monde évidemment
voilà donc pour ce pour ce match vous
nous envoyez un mail et les cinq
premiers seront donc qualifié pour jouer
contre la meilleure joueuse du monde
alors justement ça nous amène à notre
actualité de la semaine eloi nicolas
manuel c'est ce fameux match du
championnat du monde cette fois féminin
susa polgar champion du monde en titre
qui fait part de son mécontentement sur
l'organisation de ce championnat du
monde
alors votre avis sur les réactions la
championne alors je sais pas peut-être
nicolas lv1 les victimes du flou de la
fidh et dans ces organisations de match
de championnat du monde que ce soit
pour les hommes pour les femmes il ya
toujours des retards pris des sponsors
qui se défilent des villes
organisatrices qu'on a du mal à trouver
tout un désordre qui arrive à ce genre
de choses c'est à dire que au moment où
on a enfin trouvé une organisation pour
un match l'un des deux participants en
l'occurrence une joueuse
dis moi c'est fini je m'étais préparé
pour l'année dernière cette année j'ai
pris d'autres engagements dans ma vie je
ne peux pas jouer ce match c'est un peu
absurde mais c'est dû certainement la
désorganisation de la fidh et ça se
passait loi qu'est ce qui va se passer
finalement pour ce match si au match de
championnat du monde donc oui donc
effectivement c'est les deux meilleures
joueuses du monde enfin si on enlève
judit polgar souza paul garde donc sa
grande soeur est championne du monde en
titre
si youn et la challenger légitime
puisqu'elle a remporté apparemment les
cycles des candidats donc le match
devrait avoir lieu alors maintenant donc
c'est les échecs féminin donc il se
trouve que c'est à paul gare à tomber
enceinte
donc elle ne peut médicalement parlant
elle n'est pas en condition pour jouer
ce match championnat du monde donc il
cherche une solution et ne trouve pas
c'est à dire que apparemment sauf souza
pôle gare va se faire tout simplement
éliminées sur tapis vert alors manuel
effectivement à ce qui se prépare c'est
un match entre galliano va ex young et
qui laisserait la champion du monde sur
le carreau
oui c'est un peu dommage c'est vrai mais
bon on gagne à moga et quand même une
joueuse très forte
c'est une des meilleures joueuses du
monde donc ça va quand même
être un match intéressant il ya aussi un
autre problème c'est que le match se
déroulerait en chine et c'est le pays
donc d'auxi youn est donc certainement
son adversaire est un peu peur de jouer
dans un terrain un petit peu dévolu à
son adversaire quoi ou de l'avoir
beaucoup de gens qui vont être là pour
la poissonnière l'a soutenu en laine ce
qu'il faut dire stéphane le plus comique
dans cette histoire c'est que ce match
galliano maxime aurait dû avoir lieu en
finale des candidates
il y a deux ans mais à l'époque galets
m'a dit non c'est en chine je ne vois là
zhu yu na a été qualifié par forfait
pour jouer contre souha polders
maintenant on vient rechercher gallia me
voir lui dans la météo en finale
directement
c'est complètement absurde mais en fait
le problème est très simple c'est que
personne n'est intéressé par
l'organisation de cet événement de toute
évidence et donc il ya que la chine qui
se propose
c'est pour ça qu'on n'arrive pas à
trouver un lieu neutre personne ne veut
organiser cette finale de championnat du
monde féminin
oui problème c'est aussi que la
meilleure joueuse tout le monde le sait
c'est judit polgar elle n'est pas
concernée
alors c'est d'autant plus difficile de
trouver un organisateur c'est un peu
comme chez les hommes pour le cheptel -
d'affidés alors que kasparov n'est pas
là peut-être que le choix final de
judith qui de 10 rebonds il ya un seul
titre mondial aux déchets qui a pas de
raison que les femmes et les hommes
soient traitées différemment et
peut-être le bon finalement et que
chaplin de féminin championnat du monde
fim et aussi peut-être intéresse moins
parce que pourquoi décider d'un titre
pour les femmes alors que le pourrais
très bien détrôner un champion du monde
masculin
oui mais il n'empêche pas que juste pour
le gard pourrait jouer le championnat du
monde féminin et jouer aussi championnat
du monde masculin le contraire n'est pas
possible un homme n'a pas le droit de
jouer chez les femmes est tout à fait le
droit de faire les deux on va voir
comment ça va se passer mais c'est vrai
que là encore on est
un espèce de l'imbroglio un sac de deux
véritables 5,2 alors autre information
importante aussi c'est que la semaine
prochaine diagonale va proposer sa
première version en espagnol c'est à
dire vous retrouverez évidemment la
version française de diagonale et la
semaine prochaine à 20 heures avec comme
présentateur gérard demuth qui
s'occupent d'un site qui s'appelle mieux
jouer aux échecs sera le présentateur
désormais d'une émission diagonale en
espagnol donc diagonale et loi avec
maintenant of the wicked chez s&p
maintient cette émission en espagnol
prend une dimension vraiment
internationale oui c'est l'objectif des
depuis le début de toute façon diagonale
c'est l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs donc émissions internationales
il faut la faire en toutes les langues
que tout le monde puisse y trouver son
compte
donc la semaine prochaine par l'espagnol
diagonale espagnol cette semaine les
lois on va mettre l'accent sur une
partie puisque la semaine dernière on a
beaucoup eu de discours et de
commentaires on a eu les meilleurs
joueurs du monde
au bout du fil on a eu un hand shirov et
on a eu le plaisir d'avoir aussi marc
closer en direct sur des banales cette
semaine on va mettre un peu plus
l'accent sur une partie de l'actualité
est ce que tu peux nous présenter cette
partie oui donc alors cette semaine nous
allons regarder la partie cojoux le
contrôle via guînes cf
j'ai toujours un problème pour prononcer
le dernier nom qui est facile d'une
orthographe acdi délicate donc au jules
c'est un joueur donc qui fluctue entre
les nationalités il est tantôt slovène
tantôt croate
si j'ai bien compris peu comment ça
marche et c'est donc il a beaucoup
d'expérience ça fait très longtemps
qu'on le voit dans les tournois les
compétitions internationales
il a représenté la slovénie enfin la
yougoslavie en général depuis très
longtemps
c'est un joueur d'un très bon niveau il
tourne toujours autour des 2600 non
serpent et loi il oscille entre croatie
et bosnie pasto béni oui oui il me
semble le tournoi qu'on va la partie
m'avoir a lieu en slovénie c'est ça qui
pensent et ce alors vers un peu trompé
alors je crois que nicolas thil est un
fan de ce joueur
d'après ce que m'a dit eloi ceux qui ne
savent plus tôt oui en règle cette fois
y est je crois que moi c'est surtout
qu'on roule que je connais un qui ne
sait faisait ses débuts
ces types il a lui qui a inventé le
fameux coup j'ai quatre dans la partie
anglaise dès le quatrième coup un coup
incroyable quand on le voit la première
fois on est stupéfait
donc il a des idées originales mais je
le connais pas bien je les ai vus à
groningen jouer les matchs des candidats
20 97 et il avait passé deux tours je
crois il est bon mais je ne connais pas
je connais pas bien son jeu je sais que
il a l'air d'avoir un jeu tranchant mais
alors peut-être avant qu'on démarre
cette partie on va finir sur votre
actualité froid nicolas tan actualité
que tu voulais que tu veux signaler la
wii que sur france inter mercredi
prochain une émission sur l'île avec
tout les fan d'échecs se branchent sur
france inter mercredi à 13h30 dans
l'émission qui a lieu tous les jours de
ladislas de hoyos qui s'appelle un jour
du siècle il revient sur des dates
importantes du baptême c'est hélas il
revient sur le 3 septembre 1972 dont
tous les amateurs d'échecs savent que
c'est le jour du couronnement de bobby
fischer le jour où il a battu ce parce
qu'il a un 21e parti à reykjavik
et on va te retrouver dans cette
émission alors oui mais c'est une
émission qui est intéressante parce
qu'il ya des archives sonores de
l'époque on entend une interview de
spassky fischer malheureusement il n'a
pas réussi à obtenir une interview de
fin des bribes sonore de fisher qui a
accordé en fait aucune interview ou très
peu et donc on est baigné dans ce moment
là et c'est des souvenirs très
intéressant et pour ceux qui ne seraient
pas au courant qui aurait mal connue ce
match on revient un peu sur les
incidents et krischer sa nervosité
toutes les suppositions d'espionnage la
mouche de trucage electronics à la
mouche dans le
dans le jeu c'est plus d'un an poule
revient sur du mal et puis donc c'est
très intéressant d'entendre aussi
l'opinion de ladislas de hoyos qui est
un amateur d'échecs mais un peu monsieur
tout le monde vis-à-vis du jeu d'échecs
complètement fasciné il est bon il a pas
compris il est allé à l'époque et
travailler à tf1 il est allé à reykjavik
sur le mage il a rien compris d'ailleurs
vous entendez le son éditorial à la
radio il dit qu' il ya lave le fou à 17
la tour a eu quatre et on entend une
mouche voler tout le monde est là pour
ceux qui comprennent c'est merveilleux
mais lui c'était il est pas des
commentaires peut-être à l'époque il y
avait non pour le nom ça n'existait pas
voilà ce que en plus c'était reykjavik
toi qui avait très peu de chances qui
les attendent dans sa langue
donc c'est ça qui manquait peut-être
voilà c'est une bonne émission elle dure
une demi-heure donc rappeler le nom de
l'émission c'est les jours du siècle
mercredi prochain donc le 30 juin à
13h30 d'accord voilà donc à ne pas rater
sur france inter bombe pour ceux qui
habitent la france où votre actualité
c'est pour manuel notre invité notre
guest star du jour
donc tu vas jouer tu es qualifié pour
jouer le championnat de france en août à
besançon à besançon je peux être donc
ils savent être l'un des plus forts je
pense je mets en france puisque je vais
le lotier va jouer ici et
je pense que cette année ça va vraiment
être très intéressant oui parce que je
crois qu'on a on va revenir donc à joël
lautier il y a john mcgraw hill donc
fort bien tout l'effort joueurs sauf
évidemment christian bauer wii qui sera
là ce qui lui je vous pose un peu là du
monde
en fait on a lieu on a le plus fort
peut-être parce que je loti etienne
bacrot sont pas qualifiés aux
championnats du monde
peut-être bien on essaie de chance en
tout cas je peux transmettre vraiment
très intéressant avec le système coupe
et la participation de lautier bacrot
dans le même tournoi plus anatolie
weiser et du cif dorfman donc tous les
meilleurs français vont être là vont
s'affronter dans ce système assez
spectaculaire qu'est le système de coupe
avec poules élimination directe aussi
programme khelouat utile soit toi aussi
c'est encore sûr mais c'est pas encore
sûr mais il ya des probabilités c'est
possible voilà il ya de grandes
probabilités que tu vois évidemment
d'habitude tu le fais
cette année les bons et pour d'autres
raisons il est possible que tu ne sois
pas mais si tu y es diagonale il sera de
l'intérieur ouais tout à fait battre par
contre le west signale aussi que manuel
ça fait longtemps que tu appelles
chauprade france depuis 96 1996 à
auxerre où je n'ai pas très bien marché
donc je vais décider pour moi un petit
peu de recul
quant aux championnats de france le bon
cette année je pense que ça va aller
mieux et donc en tout cas ancien titré
92,92 champion de france donc tu vas
récupérer ton bien voilà bon mais on va
peut-être enchaîner maintenant sûrement
partie du jour alors pendant qu'on met
là la vidéo de la partie
donc à disposition je vous rappelle que
vous pouvez suivre aussi cette partie en
cliquant sur l'icône jouer à gauche donc
du texte de présentation de diagonale
vous entrez sur un applet java qui
propose la partie vous avez aussi la
possibilité de télécharger la partie
grâce à un fichier pgn qui est
disponible aussi dans le texte de
présentation et qui peut être vue grâce
à des logiciels que nous proposons en
téléchargement dans notre parti archives
de l'émission en cliquant sur l'icône
émission en haut de la page
voilà donc au gp fini ses présentations
et là je crois qu'on peut démarrer cette
très jolie partie oui donc juste un
dernier mot sur un swing cf
c'est un joueur classique de l'école
russe 600 tr knight du ritz qui y l'ol
joue très bien le calcul très bien et
surtout sa particularité c'est qu'il est
très original il n'a aucun disons aucun
tabou il est capable de jouer vraiment
tous les coups
du moment qu'ils ont une certaine
audace il peut jouer comme tu disais
nicolas g4 dans une position
gk déception qui est devant le cavalier
c'est pas un coup centrale c'est un coût
plutôt affaiblissant on peut plus faire
le petit rock après pourtant ils
n'hésitent pas à employer ce coup là
assez récemment enfin régulièrement vers
je dirais qu'il a joué dans différentes
positions donc c'est un joueur très très
original alors il a les noirs et les
blancs sont menées par kozun qu'aux
joueurs ouais voilà donc début de la
partie très très classique un des quatre
cavaliers f6 cavaliers f3 donc là il
s'écoula on les a commentées de
nombreuses fois dans des diagonales
donc on va essayer de passer un peu haut
niveau au dessus g6 donc là c'est un
système qu'on appelle d'options kétou
stéphane donc l'idée est de mettre sous
le fouet fuite
angers7 nous y contrôlera la grande
diagonale donc vous voyez toutes les
cases ici en jaune fait le fou et
exercera une action très très longue sur
sur tout l'échiquier tout simplement et
autres avantages de cette formation
c'est que le roi se trouve parfaitement
sécurisés dans avec le petit rock
vous voyez que là les pions donc ici
vont défendre bien les cases blanches
alors que le fou quand j'essaie de
défendre ali kazma donc le ça fera un
petit rock très compacte
l'inconvénient de cette ouverture c'est
que sa cèdent le centre au blanc donc
les avantages sont simples le fou sur la
grande diagonale développer d'une façon
très agressive
le roi bien en sécurité et inconvénients
principal on se bat pas du tout pour les
quatre centrales
donc là les blancs bien entendu prennent
le centre voyez ce fameux duo de pions
dont on a beaucoup parlé dans les
émissions précédentes qui contrôlent ces
quatre cases l'a bien avancé dans le
camp ennemi
donc les blancs en fait prennent le
centre tout ça très classique fou g7 on
met le front fuyant kétou donc emmener
au troisième coup et là elle est blanche
ou quatre cavaliers c3 donc encore un
coup logique de développement un
cavalier sans vers le centre protège
contrôler une case centrale notamment et
donc la case en 4 si tu peux la montrer
voilà donc le ce cavalier bien placer
mon coup normal de développement voiture
l'instant les deux joueurs suivent les
préceptes de l'ouverture voyez alors ici
deux embranchements
principaux sont conseillés par la
théorie soit joué la partie est indienne
très tranchantes et où les noirs s'être
complètement le centre simplement pour
attaquer vers le roi blanc ou alors la
défense grünfeld qui a été employée ici
c'était c'est un peu plus un peu plus
rapide on lut un peu plus pour le centre
donc je rappelle les stades yann ça
serait tout est petit rock et laisser
les scellés blanc jouer au 2e 4 qui
prendra un contrôle absolu du centre
alors que la grogne feltz et la partie
ou alors il ya une stratégie loi il ya
une 3e option c'est les coups c'est
cette c5 tu veux nous anglais wait
donc au bout de poule à des joueurs qui
excusez moi petit petit dérapage le coup
donc ses 7 ans et 5
ce coup là on augmentait la l'action du
fou sur la grande diagonale qui est un
coup aussi
et donc là on a ri risquez rien des
structures de benoni si je me trompe pas
le d4 d5
oui c'est en fait ça c'est une idée
encore plus dynamique s'est tu c'est
beaucoup plus rapide que les stands yann
c'est à dire qu'on dit tout de suite
voilà mon fou g7 je vais le faire jouer
maintenant je vais pas attendre je vais
je vais vraiment toujours et pour le fou
g7 donc c'est ça on va peut-être
expliquer pourquoi surcoûts possibles
aussi donc on est dans le branchement
donc on peut quand même commenté un
petit peu ce coup c'est cette c5
attaquant le pion des quatre pour le
dévier pour dévier si les blancs par
exemple prennent du coup le fou noir
tout de suite contrôler un maximum de
cases vers le camp blanc et le pion
blanc ans enseigne ne serait pas sain
que celui du procès cinq voile blanc ne
pourrait pas tellement le protégé donc
ce serait une concession sur les cases
noires disons que sur ces cinq les
blancs ont tendance à jouer des cinq
pour assurer un contrôle compacte du
centre avec des pions qui se tiennent et
là on arrive dans les embranchements de
la benoni qu'une idée d'ouverture les
plus compliqué à analyser actuellement
donc ici les noirs ont joué quatre des
cinq là donc la fameuse défense du
nouvel employé par kasparov énormément
contre karpov tout le match
new york je crois quand on voit que pas
beaucoup de succès d'ailleurs pour
casper ouais mais je crois que tous les
champions du monde plus ou moins utilisé
cette variante une fischer évidemment
été un grand adepte aussi de ses otaries
que la jouer oui pas talent je crois pas
li petrossian ainsi petrossian n'ont pas
trop si on les trouve sur la page the
two déconfite a enfin mentionné une
ouverture dans classique
voici sa cuisse le fonds noté peut-être
écrire avec non c'est vrai en plus qu'a
donc non pas tous à leur intervention
ça fait partie des risques variés que
tout cela en fait c'est fisher et
kasparov pour moi ça fait tout ça pour
ça mais non mais en fait c'est
exactement ça c'est une ouverture qui
réservé aux joueurs qui cherchent le
dynamisme avec les noirs c'est quand
même pas donné à tout le monde
puisqu'elle est noir on attend
satisfaire d'une partie nulle là
vraiment ça donne des positions assez
compliqué où le combat a lieu tout de
suite tout de suite en conflit au centre
un vous voyez ici
4e coup déjà il ya contact pions le fond
g7 qui peut ressurgir
donc c'est vraiment les joueurs qui
cherchent un peu la baston dès le début
quoi ouverture donc très agressive et
l'a donc embranchements un peu je dirais
une sous variante joué par caujolle 5-fu
g5 c'est pas le coût principal est là
normalement on joue cavalier au 4 mai
donc baggins f a sa propre idée sur la
question
et jouer un peu une vente subsidiaire
disons en réponse à une sous variantes
qui joue lui-même une somme variant tu
pourquoi pas il joue donc dépensé 4 qui
n'est pas le coût principal est donc ici
on a cédé complètement la case au
quatrain vous voyez en compensation n'a
gagné un pion on a pris de chance et cap
qui n'est pas récupérable de suite par
les blancs voilà les remarques générales
et envisager d'envahir le centre tout de
suite d'ailleurs avec les au coût de 4
c'est le coup le plus analysé ici 2 4
mais ça n'a pas été le choix de cojoux
sans doute est-ce qu'il a été surpris
par la prise du pion ses caprices et
méfier il n'a pas voulu rentrer dans la
voilà c'est encore le thème et des
tourments des grands tournois c'est que
c'est pas forcément les meilleurs coups
qui sont les plus intéressants si les
coûts comprenant surtout surprenant
celui qui surprend le premier
l'adversaire petit avantage
psychologique donc ici c'est surprise
surprise pour ainsi dire il faut que
j'aie 5 surprise dépensé 4 surprise et
6e coup et 3 encore une surprise
voilà donc il va faire consolider son
simple plutôt de l'envahir et son fou
maintenant vise le pion c4 pour le
récupérer
oui d'ailleurs si les blancs venaient je
vous prends ces quatre îles obtiendrez
un petit avantage dans la mesure où leur
centre est quand même assez stable avec
les pions des 4es et 3es si jamais on
jouait donc fait fin profession c4 ici
on achèvera le développement très
rapidement avec petit rock on aurait
sorti toutes nos pièces en continuant à
contrôler le centre
donc en fait les blancs auraient achevé
tous les objectifs principaux de
l'ouverture qui sont le rappel prendre
le centre sortir les pièces mineurs et m
leroy la breizh donc ici les noirs s'y
oppose et joue donc au sixième bout faut
aussi ce un coup normalement un peu
surprenante donc moi j'ai mis très très
longtemps avant de comprendre qu'on
pouvait jouer ce genre de coups puisque
pour moi c'est complètement anti
positionnelle dans la mesure où on
bloque un pion moi je personnellement je
n'ai pas mes pièces devant les pions
donc l'avouer que le fou en russie ce
bloc l'option hausse est de l'avis des
lois
je pense que les noirs profite du fait
que les blancs n'ont pas joué justement
le coup de quatre pour pousser au centre
et ont la possibilité de mettre ce fou
en eux six pour défendre leurs pions si
le pion blanc avaient en eux quatre ils
n'auraient pas pu faire ça de la poussée
des cinq d'accord par exemple donc je
pense qu'il profite de ça est bon les
seuils de garder son pion plus longtemps
possible ce qui paraît finalement assez
naturel quant aux pions e7 qui peut pas
avancer c'est vrai mais bon je pense pas
que l'idée des noirs soit d'avancer ses
pions en tout cas pour l'instant
donc je pense un coup finalement assez
logique
le traitement moderne enfin moi quand je
disais que je voulais pas jouer vous
aussi c'était il ya quand même assez
longtemps effectivement maintenant ça me
paraît un coup quand même comme dit
manuela c'est finalement assez logique
d'accord donc aucun cookie donc empêche
les blancs de reprendre facilement ce
pion et donc pose la question
donc là donc cojoux la choisissent 7e
cook a validé deux nokla nous avons
consulté tout à l'heure la base de
données avec nicolas et le coût
principal dans cette position nicolas
c'était cavaliers aux cinq effectivement
ça a l'air plus logique quand même
regarder ici on a mis le cavalier f3 sur
cette case en d2 donc en repli et
toujours pour prendre ce pion c4 voilà
donc maintenant le cavalier le fou
attaque le pion c4 protégé par une seule
pièce le côté noir faut aussi simple
proposer le coup donc cavalier e 5 avait
l'air de remplir aussi cet objectif en
étant plus agressif
ouais tout à fait ici cavaliers f-35
vous ressembler à ces logiques
effectivement d'ailleurs c'est le coût
principal beaucoup de beaucoup de
parties a vraiment beaucoup de parties
de grands champions donc aucune surprise
ici qu'aux jo ne connaît la position
c'est sûr
probablement il choisit qu'à valider
d'eau qui est plus restreint peut-être
qu'il voulait jouer plus solide cette
partie je sais pas c'est un coup qu'on
ne peut pas expliquer ce qui se passe
dans la tête de cochon
tant qu'on lui a pas demandé on sait pas
pourquoi il choisit qui avaient des deux
plutôt cavaliers aux 5 c'est sûrement
une raison de plus psychologique que
assez assez clairement
il semble que je vais à guînes s'est
fait un style tranchant comme on disait
tout à l'heure et qui doit aimer les
positions violentes alors que joue avec
cavaliers des deux sans doute un peu
plus prudent voilà ça donne un jeu sans
doute un peu plus qu'à l'occasion un peu
plus psychologique que technique disons
de ce coup plutôt que de l'autre le
cavalier 5 étant dans le carnet noir
plus agressif que je préfère un coup un
peu plus prudent en gardant ses pièces
dans son camp en fait oui que jouent les
avantages de l'expérience donc il peut
se dire que s'ils emmène la partie sur
le long terme notamment en finale il va
pouvoir peut-être remporter une victoire
un peu plus facilement que dans les
complications de mieux que ça c'est
possible aussi
alors qu'en fait notre amie et donc la
sncf ne perd pas de temps il attaque le
centre tout de suite et joue loeffel
donc le coût de typique de la grotte
fait l'un l'option c'est cette avance
ans et cinq attaquants donc le clan des
4 ou avec le fou g7 est placé en rayons
x vers ce pion la dame des huit
également donc là toutes les pièces
noires en fait attaque attaque ce point
des quatre qui vient d'être affaiblie
par les blancs qui viennent d'enlever un
protecteur qui était le cavalier f3 pour
le mettre en d2 donc réaction très
logique de ce green sa fille si hélas le
coup de cause il m'a beaucoup surpris je
dois reconnaître il a joué au huitième
coup sûr votre applet java 8/8 coude et
blanc font un f6 alors peut-être manuel
da une explication personnellement je
trouve ce coup il utile mauvais ouais
c'est à dire que le fou n'étant pas
attaqué pourquoi les prendre
un cavalier dont on sait tous que quand
même en principe a priori et en toute
bonne bonne foi le fou est plus fort que
le cavalier légèrement le coût normal
aura été de reprendre le pion c4 tout de
suite c'est ça oui dans le cavalier ou
bien prendre ses seins sont très
naturels sur le réseau plus tard à moins
et noir avaient bougé le fou blanc
serait resté un peu stupide sur la casse
g5 à une pièce qui est plutôt fragile
peut-être la raison voilà peut-être bon
alors autre explication possible c'est
qu'il a prévu en fait l'enchaînement de
coûts qui va suivre mais qui ne me
paraît pas favorable pour les blancs
donc en fait à mon avis ce coup c'est le
début d'un plan erronées de la part de
la part des blancs mauvaise évaluation
mauvais bilan mauvais bino enfin le
bilan est à faire encore francis coup
franc à six et la cause ou l'enchaînent
avec neuf cavaliers de4 attaque double
oui il faut noter qu'ils pouvaient pas à
reprendre le pion c4 désormais parce que
lui-même ou sans entrave l autre pion
attaqué le pion des quatre oui oui tout
à fait ça qui ne veut pas jouer le coup
naturel de reprendre dans ses cartons et
donc mettez ainsi les blancs qui dit
nicolas reprennent avec leurs cavaliers
ou leur fou le pion c4 oui c'est le
pilote d 4d blanc qui laisse ou la prise
du pion ces cinq nouvelles 6,6 et
l'adami évite donc les bleus ne peuvent
pas se permettre de perdre ça fait trop
donc ici qu'à valider vos quatre donc là
on va les éliminer un attaquant c'est à
dire que le cavalier est prêt à jouer
apprendre le foie fils donc récupérer un
peu cette paire de fou et autre avantage
c'est qu'on attaque aussi l'option ses
5e jeux qui avaient pensé 5 signifie
d'un recul leur fou que les blancs
peuvent prendre ce pion c5 avec le
cavalier une position carrière agréable
elle position excellente dans la mesure
où le fou donc on peut supposer que les
noirs ici j'aurais fou g7
bonjour et cavaliers e400 croupion c5 et
là alors on verrait que le fou g7 est
complètement emmuré devant cette
phalange d'options donc des pions qui se
protègent entre eux c'est très fort
contre un fou
ici le fou g7 serait en mesure et le
québec c'est ce rac obtiendra une
position dominante
vraiment très dominantes et noir en
repli de ce qu'on appelle de rupture
puisque l'audience et qui peuvent
attaquer le plan des aurait disparu
aurait disparu tout à fait donc une
position centrale très fort pour les
blancs donc ici une option inacceptable
complètement donc s'éprend des cartes
très logique ici si on joue on prend des
quatre avec les blancs je vais pointer
quand même maintenant il y aurait
simplement dame prend des quatre voire
même fou pendant des 4 c'est à dire que
l'option serait encore emprise donc les
blancs jouent ce qu'on appelle un coup
intermédiaire stéphanie joue cavalier
pour un f6 avec l'échec avec échec c'est
pour ça que c'est un très bon
intermédiaire ici le cou noir et forcé
on peut pas envisager d'autres coûts
puisque le roi est en échec
il faut reprendre le cavalier maintenant
on a éliminé un peu cette pression sur
le tour des quatre qui était le fief 6
et on va reprendre en d4
je prends des 4 et là c'est l'heure du
bilan j'espère encore un viande -
absente - mais ils ont une menace assez
forte c'est à dire qu'ils ont un pion
donc le pion des quatre qui est passé
c'est à dire qui peut avancer ses pions
nana personnes devant lui il n'y a pas
d'opposition de haut niveau des pions et
si on joue des quatre des cinq le fou e6
va être attaqué en prise comme ça il
faudra qu'ils partent
et là on pourra prendre l'option c4 avec
le faut afin donc la menace ici blanche
est très claire d4 d5
s'il arrive à jouer il n'y a pas de
problème ils vont être mieux dans la
mesure où ils ont un pion central de
plus et que de l'autre côté les noirs
ont quand même un petit affaiblissement
de structures de pions avec cette option
doublé donc ici tout à fait logique plus
ou moins forcé les noirs jouent food et
5 davantage ce coup c'est que ça bloque
le pion le pion blanc qui ne peut plus
avancer
et donc ça empêche évidemment les blancs
de mener ce plan que tu viens de citer
en fait purement défensif ou en actions
ça a effectué un blocage aussi du pian
d4 et là on arrive dans une pression qui
est plus ou moins critique puisque c'est
là que cojo là a dû a eu à faire un
choix et donc notre analyse et qu'il n'a
pas fait le bon choix
donc alors quels sont les choix dans
cette position donc manuel tout à
l'heure tu proposé de jouer cavalier
prend food et 5
donc là je préfère prévenir avant qu'on
commence les variantes vous ne vont pas
être simples à suivre
on va on va peut-être donner les deux
trois grandes vagues possibles avec les
idées peut-être derrière avec les idées
derrière mais on peut récupérer son
concurrent fait ça veut dire en prenant
le fou puis en faisant la dame échec
auront eu deux d'accord donc free
simplement la kabylie ces trois profs ou
des 5
la dame viendrait reprendre ce fou et là
on jouerait d'âme des uns en e2 échec au
roi donc très un échec très long et on
viendrait prendra ensuite l'option c4
qui seraient protégés par le fouet f1
donc ça c'est une vente assez simple
effectivement kid qui pourrait être
poursuivie avec le pen donc il faut
juger la position après évidemment
toujours les blancs auraient un pion
tout seul au centre qui seraient passés
mes possibilités pour les noirs
d'échanger les dames probablement dans
cette variante
elle est arrivée dans une finale où le
pion pourrait s'avérer plus faible que
fort peut-être non alors mon avis c'est
pas ça puisque dans cette finale
les blancs on aurait tous les avantages
ils ont un fou contre un cavalier ce qui
est plus fort puisque ya des pions sur
des deux côtés de l'échiquier ça on
l'avait déjà dit donc le fouet allant
plus vite d'une pas d'un bout à l'autre
de l'échiquier que lecavalier et plus
efficace quand l'adoption dispersés en
plus au niveau de la structure d'options
les blancs n'ont pas de problème ils ont
un pion passé centrale alors que les
noirs leurs pions de plus ne serait pas
sentir puisque il est doublé on le
rappelle ici
l'option de puiser noir et un f6 donc
cela va très récente c'est devant tu as
l'air très intéressante
mon analyse c'est que c'est pour des
motifs tactique causual n'a pas joué ça
donc alors pour deux raisons la première
c'est qu'enfin deux variantes
il y aurait d'amd 5e quatre échecs qui
pose des problèmes défensifs donc là
pour les experts qui suivent il ya des
inconvénients devant chaque défense et
l'autre l'autre hypothèse c'est que que
joue la jouer ce qu'il a joués en
pensant que c'était très fort
et donc il n'a pas bien réalisé ce qui
allait lui arriver ce qui est également
possible
d'accord il a peut-être vu une voirie a
vu une brindille croyait avoir gagné il
a pas peut-être décidé de la jouer sans
semble bien l'avoir calculer et donc il
est tombé dans l'eau peut-être dans le
piège
oui de toute façon il ya toujours un
problème quand on voit une variante qui
est un petit peu meilleures pour nous et
sans risque une vente qui a des chances
de gagner mais qui est un peu risqué
le joueur pratiquement toujours la vente
qui a une chance de gagner
donc ici c'est peut-être ce que caujolle
a joué il a donc choisi un autre
embranchements plutôt que de jouer qu'il
prend des cinq aidé à me deux échecs il
a joué deuxième coûte damas quatre
échecs au roi donc là pas de il n'y a
pas beaucoup de solutions
si on couvre cet échec donc là je vais
pointer l'échec de la dame vers le roi
donc bouger le droit ça serait pas une
très bonne solution
enfin je veux roi est fluide ça a pas
l'air en tout cas ce n'est pas
constructif et couvrir avec la dame pour
arriver en finale ça l'inconvénient de
perdre une pièce puisqu'après d'un
programme
le food et 5 ne serait plus défendu et
donc le cas et c'est 3 viendra le
prendre donc ici en fait qui fait d'une
pierre deux coups c'est à dire qu'il va
par l échec au roi en développant une
pièce qui est tout à fait logique
je veux donc au deuxième coupe cavaliers
c6 donc là les noirs sont toutes leurs
pièces merengues plus car hockey et vise
le pion central des bleus ont surtout et
le plan et le pian 2 des 5 est alors pas
tous pas attaquer tout de suite puisque
le cavalier avec l'aurait il fait
pression il fait pression quand même
qu'elle et ses 6 et la dame des 800
prêts à bondir sur ce pion donc ici que
je continue ça entre guillemets
combinaison en jouant dans b5
alors là il ya des problèmes pour les
noirs
et un problème certain le food et
s'inquiètant prises maintenant avec la
dame et le cavalier la dame attaque
le cavalier attaque donc tout ça vous
voyez pointé sur ce fou des 5 et 6 le
food et 5
revenez en os 6 on pourra jouer la
fourchette en avançant simplement de
chant des quatre qui attaquera ce moment
là les deux pièces le cas les c6 et de
fossiles donc là il ya un problème très
clair pour les noirs alors comment on
fait alors alors on va jouer en fait ce
qu'a joué la fncf qui est très bas 9 que
je trouve assez joli c'est pour ça que
j'ai sélectionné cette partie en fait un
pur pour cette semaine il a joué dame
cet échec petit échec donc maintenant si
on vient couvrir cet échec
non vous voyez ici un échec très long si
on vient couvrir avec le fou donc on met
le fou sur cette case en a eu deux le
food et 5 à ce qu'on l'a viendrait
prendre l'option g2 qui serait plus
défendue si on couvre avec autre chose
par exemple avec le cavalier si on met
le pied ces trois ce toujours sur cette
case eux deux sont là le fou n'est plus
attaquées qu'une seule fois et on peut
jouer gros rock défendant le fou donc
ici les blancs pour conserver un peu
tous leurs atouts dans cette position
qui est la taille du fou des 5 et la
perspective de jouer des quatre des cinq
ans le fou 120 doivent se dérouler donc
au jeu continue sur sa lancée ici on est
dans une vente très tactique très fort
c'est les deux joueurs ont dû bien
calculer et bien posé leurs coûts en
fait chaque coup est très important dans
une série de coups depuis tout à l'heure
où kozuka estimé la position finale donc
c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
les deux joueurs ont calculé cette série
de coups ils réfléchissent évidemment à
chaque coup encore une fois mais ils ont
bien pesé tout ça au départ en arizona
un des coûts forcé depuis deux coups
mais voilà force et enfin oui en plus
d'être forcés je dirais plutôt que
l'importance de chacun des coûts est
capital une erreur dans ce genre de
variantes et la partie s'arrête de suite
donc vraiment les joueurs la passe la
majeure partie de leur temps de
réflexion sachant qu'ensuite dès que la
position sera calmée dès qu'on arrivera
dans une position technique où on pourra
faire un bilan calme et des plans
simples on pourra jouer positions très
critiques est un peu déséquilibré sur le
plan statique dynamique
je dirais donc il joue au roi des deux
ceux des records et conservant son
attaque sur le fou dessin pour clouer la
taille puisque danemark devant le roi
est sous le feu de la tour maintenant
davantage ce coup c'est que la tour
blanche peut venir en jeu attaquant la
dame noire avec le roi derrière ce qui
est toujours très désagréable tout à
fait c'est la menace d'autant plus que
le faux est encore attaqué malheur ici
soit gensel jouent un très joli coup à
moins qu'ils aient mon avis est le coût
de la partie donc on en est au 14e coup
des blancs viennent de jouer en 3d 2 et
la superbe 14 grand roque donc un peu
difficile à comprendre sur le coup c'est
vrai le food et s'inquiètant prise il
est attaqué par la dame et par le
cavalier donc ce fou et attaqué deux
fois mais il a défendu qu'une fois à
laver mais par contre les noirs ont
réactivé tout leur séjour
le roi est sorti du centre donc la
deuxième tour pour revenir en jeu aussi
donc effectivement c'est un peu le thème
qu'on a déjà vu ses relais noir sacrifie
du matériel contre une activation
maximale de leur potentiel d'attac tout
à fait toutes les pièces noires sont
vraiment en jeu c'est bien dans l'esprit
de la défense d'une fade c'est kasparov
a toujours joué ça comme ça le matériel
n'a pas une grosse importance qui compte
c'est un mobilisation rapide de toutes
les forces question pour les landes
c'est savoir est ce que le roi
finalement maintenant est bien placé ils
vont gagner une molette renonce à ces
punks là non je veux dire placer les mal
classés c'est sûr donc maintenant les
blancs sont obligés d'accepter le cadeau
grecque
je dirais puisque si on prend pas la
pièce la position n'a plus aucun intérêt
si on prend pas ce kode5 hockey prend
des 5 et forcé et là on continue
festival enfin disons commence le
festival tout reprend des cinq qu'on en
est au 15e coup la tourette emprise
donc la dame vient prendre cette tour
donc la séquence force et on passe
rapidement et dernier coup de ce bug ncf
dans cette position forcé tour des huit
alors là qu'est ce qui se passe
très simple les blancs ou une tour de
plus ils ont la dame qui a attaqué par
cette tour des huit et l'option des
quatre également est en prise par le
cavalier c6 et la tour donc le pion des
cartes va sauter au cou d'après les
noirs vont jouer à tourcoing des 4
quelle que soit la case où la dame à ya
donc ici il ya plusieurs variantes
possibles mais la dame a pas beaucoup de
casse déjà stefan wey dans cette
position toutes les cases sont contrôlés
1 pour la dame précieux effectivement
que la dame en plus par exemple on peut
imaginer que si la dame prend le pion la
latin ne peut pas prendre le thé en fait
puisque la tour prendrait le pion des
quatre avec échec
oui en fait la dame serait perdu donc en
fait c'est là c'est la partie c'est la
partie la joie d'un pensée caf
alors il peut pas sauver seul homme il
peut conserver donc il peut pas essayer
de sauver sa dame parce qu'en fait il a
calculé qu'il y avait une attaque de
maths
il ya une attaque de mattel en sort dmb
5 on s'était amusé avec manuela calculé
tout à l'heure il ya un coût très
souvent c'est à 7 à 6 on pose encore une
fois la question à la dame donc je vais
plus ou moins indiqué cette variante
comme on peut la dame viendrait ici on
mettre l'option 2 à 7 ans à six
attaquants la dame attaquant la dame qui
devrait choisir une nouvelle case ça va
nous entraîner dans des vagues
compliquent et stéphane d'accord mais il
se trouve qu'après au final la dame n'a
pas de case finalement de six yards en
fait c'est le roi qui sait le roi c'est
le sait les rois c'est le rock animal si
la chauffer un peu parce que en végétaux
reprend des 4 es le roi ne saura plus où
aller en fait il ya des ventes de mac
force et pratiquement tout le temps donc
diversion sur la dame est finalement
matt
voilà l'idée l'idée est un d'éloigner la
pièce de la défense et de mater et si la
pièce reste elle est perdue
ce qui est remarquable c'est que la
seule pièce en jeu chez les blancs c'est
la dame
hormis évidemment le roi avec est pas
vraiment une pièce mais oui c'est vrai
que tout est mobilisée chez les noirs et
chez les blancs c'est vrai que les deux
tours on sent les starting blocks et
encore les tours et le fou et le fou n'a
pas encore sorti de sa case
il ya moins de matchs et noir mais ils
sont tout le matériel est actif c'est
dans le camp blanc il ya vu un faux
départ comme au départ d'une course de
sprint
la dame serait partie seule avant les
autres qui sont restés sur le starting
blocks
alors voyons ce qui se passe il est joué
d'avancé 4 désespéré et suis en galère
on peut noter quand même que les blancs
ont déjà une tour de plus par contre et
blanc ont déjà une tour de plus ça
suffit pas de calculs et qu'on va
récupérer la dame parce que on peut
considérer que d'auto valent une dame
il faut aussi juger si la dame et le
cavalier et qui va rester en jeu ou
peuvent être suffisant pour mettre en
déséquilibre les blancs parce que sinon
on peut imaginer que si les blancs il va
se regrouper avec deux tours contre une
dalle ou peuvent même avoir un avantage
ouais tout à fait bon alors de toute
façon là c'est un peu trop tôt pour
dresser le bilan puisqu'il ya encore
deux coups forcé qui viennent donc tout
reprend des quatre ou dix septième ou
dame prend des quatre qu'elle prend des
4 c'est ici qu'on peut commencer à faire
un bilan
voilà donc là on peut dire que là toute
la combinaison qui dure depuis une
dizaine de coups les terminer les deux
joueurs auraient dû voir à cette
position et à juger sur pièce il
semblerait que cause ou ne ramenaient
pas vu exactement cette possibilité que
ce soit plutôt son adversaire à mon avis
au niveau de l'évaluation la position
les joueurs n'ont pas pu se tromper
je sais pas manu tu vas peut-être me
contredire mais ici cette position ça me
paraît clair que les noirs ont davantage
non avantage c'est sûr donc c'est les
blancs qui on m'a jugé on a dit que les
pièces blanches ne s'était pas développé
c'est toujours le cas et on voit que le
roi blanc au centre est vraiment très
faible devant la dame et les cavaliers
on sait que la paire dames et qui avait
dit est très forte entre l'euro un
échantillon représentatif de toutes les
pièces de l'échiquier
la dame faisant tour est fou et le
cavalier faisant cavalier on arrive à
représenter toutes les pièces donc
l'efficacité maximum
toutes les possibilités de déplacement
sont représentés par ces deux pièces
toutes les lignes géométriques ya aucune
case disons qui peut être à l'abri
exactement donc en fait principe général
pour pour les internautes qui nous
regardent le duo dames et cavaliers très
fort comparé la dame est fou alors en
revanche pour la tour c'est le duo tour
fou qui est beaucoup plus fort que le
duo tour cavaliers donc principe général
intégrant donc ici avantage noir sans
aucun doute puisque on a déjà un pion
pour les deux tours et le fameux duo
dames et cavaliers et le développement
blanc qui n'est toujours pas déterminée
lépine le roi blanc surtout qui est
catastrophique donc ici il n'est pas
vraiment question de faire une
évaluation purement matérielle c'est
tous les autres facteurs qui remporte la
palme de l'évaluation par le plus en
plus même n'est pas tant le club plus
c'est vrai coeur il n'a pas un gros
intérêt donc il a un coût de
développement avec tempo ce qu'on
appelle avec tempo il joue 19 tours
c'est un échec mais ton tour en jeu
faisant échec au roi donc les noirs on
est obligé de bouger le roi ce qu'ils
font grimper vite donc on a plus ou
moins gagner un temps puisque le
courroux avait vite n'est pas pas
vraiment un coût de développement pour
pour ainsi dire maintenant se pose le
problème de développement du fou alors
là gros problème pour cause on se
demande pourquoi que joue la menthe à
l'eau ne pourrait pas sortir son fou
pari sur la case aux trois cas les airs
logique donc ça doit être un jeu ces
pièces la caisse des trois ans et après
de la case d3 pardon et amener la tour
qui est sur le coin de l'échiquier à un
jeu via le centre oui vous avez tout à
fait alors dame b 4 échecs
oui probablement la dame devient va de 7
ans b 4 avec échec ou rouen assez
l'ennui c'est que ce roi est très mal
placé en fait c'est ça qui empêche un
peu les blancs ça enlèverait une case ou
noir ou en blanc peut-être si vous avez
le droit ils pourraient de l'échangé
mais n'ont pas le droit d'échanger le
roi quand il n'a pas l'aura décharger
les pièces noir et blanc veulent parer
de dâm sen
prochain les blancs ou 20 tours c4 pour
éviter en fait dans ses intentions
réelles oppositions les blancs cherche à
faire une formation qui soit une espèce
de forteresse dans la mesure où sur le
long terme ils peuvent prendre
l'aventage donc la forteresse ça
consiste en quoi ça consiste à mettre
des pièces pour les positions et stable
nouvelles peuvent pas de déloger donc
ici 20 tours c4 c'est le début un peu de
une forteresse puisque on empêche la
dame de venir donner un échec ici en
même temps on ne tape ce cavalier masqué
pas si mal et au prochain coup on pourra
jouer food et 3 si tout se passe bien
suivi de tours humains et là on aura
quand même contrôlé beaucoup de cas
votre moment là donc ça c'est un peu
l'idée
il faut chercher une pierre pour le roi
dont on pourra pas délogés en
l'occurrence pour l'instant et protège
la casse des deux d'accord alors d'un
mot 4 diversion toujours où on vient des
phares avec une petite peut-être une
petite menaces n'ont pas de petites
menaces a fait partie aux coûts
cavaliers f3 avec échec
oui c'est intéressant mais le
malheureusement donc l'idée de ces ce
coup c'est de prendre la tour je pense
stéphane mais voilà c'est la rigueur qui
malheureusement a défendu par le fou à
windsor intervenir trois points
cavaliers tout à fait voilà qui serait
très problématique si effectivement on
fait c'est de faire pression sur les
pions blancs d'oeufs les droits oui et
donc d'empêcher le développement du four
oui tout à fait whale en fait ce coup
attaque le pion g2 ici donc se
refléteront aujourd'hui d'un projet de
simplement essayer attaquerez de
l'option f2 et la tourache voilà
obligeant la nature à bouger on a
récupéré des jeunes plus en plus ça
commence à faire beaucoup
commence à faire beaucoup donc et ont
donc autre idée cette fois un peu
défensive on défend le cavalier des
quatre très importants comme été attaqué
donc là que joue la sent que sa position
n'est pas bonne mais ne peut pas faire
grand chose ils jouent h 4 à peut-être
avec didier d'activer sa tour à un
développement un peu
pervers je dirais je proposais un coup
ah oui oui tout à fait roi en c3
carrément attaqué le cavalier comme ça
qui cloué alors donc revenons à cette
position là je vais enlever ces cases
jaune donc nicolas tu propose de jouer
éventuellement roi des deux en c3
intéressant alors attaqué le roi attaque
aurait un en attaque donc le cavalier le
cavalier ou quatre mètres carrés
pourrait faire un échec sur la face b 5
le khalife le prolongement des saints le
roi n'est pas vraiment un pour imaginer
le roi monte encore sur la case bc oui
ou revient où il était propre et non oui
et non c'est très complexe et complexée
d'avoir été difficile je pense que
globalement ça change un peu
l'évaluation générale de cette pression
des coûts possibles effectivement qu'il
a dû d'acculer il a estimé qu'il veut
c'est de construire comme tu disais tout
à l'heure plutôt que de partir d'un des
complications comme ça donc il a calculé
qu'elle n'était pas forcément bonnes à
la fin continuer à construire sa
forteresse donc activer la dernière
pièce qui ne jouent pas tout à fait
encore c'est la tour 7 tours en h1 gens
se cachent quatre oui puisque c'est vrai
que le fouet fin en fait est fait
participent déjà à l'action
puisqu'ils contrôlent ces quinze
importante et défend la tour c 4 donc la
seule vraie pièce qui n'est pas en jeu
ses sept tours en h1 ici donc il joue h
4 l'idée développement de la tourache 3
et l'a donc maintenant les noirs jouent
dynamique il faut pas oublier que si les
blancs se regroupent
ça peut être bon pour eux donc il faut
absolument casser cette espèce de
forteresse donc il joue b5 délogeant la
tour c 4 qui ne peut pas rester là donc
maintenant stéphane spécialement pour
toi si tours b 4 on pourrait jouer ta
combinaison je veux dire maintenant ça
marche
voilà qui marcherait puisque le tour ne
serait plus défendu et donc la dame
viendrait choper la tour au coup d'après
donc on peut pas rester sur la quatrième
manche est donc très logiquement où on
est passé un peu vite
il ya une accélération donc 22 tours c3
on ne pouvait pas rester sur la 4ème
manger on peut plus donc attaquer le
cavalier plus attaquées ce qui libère
donc la dame noire quotidien maintenant
poser des questions voilà donc crucial
quand le car blanc d'un bien attaque le
cube et 2 l'option à deux et empêche le
fou de sortir et la tour puisque s'il
faut bouge le fou vient d'être cloué la
dame lath aurait perdu et si la tour
bouge c'est le fou qui fait foi est
perdu donc là il mobilise les blancs et
sur leur créer des problèmes je pense
que d'hommes bien c'est un coup décisif
à la dame de faire un carnage maintenant
tous les pions ange tous les pions sont
ils passés ici c'est vraiment c'est
l'agonie à leur vendent donc là le plan
de nicolas enfin si on peut appeler ça
un plomb à 23 3 ou 6 mois estival à
gauche une fois l'alerté passée à côté
d'un coup de pied on peut pas trop
s'échapper en tête donc d'un pro b 2
tout se passe oui c'est un joli
sacrifice de cavelier oui le cavalier
temps prise mais en fait les noirs
auraient le coût est effectivement assez
un sacrifice aux enfants disent si le
roi prendre et que la cour ne peut plus
bouger donc suffi pour les noirs de
jouer le coup b50 b4 et la tour ne peut
pas échapper à sa prise tout à fait donc
lecavalier n'est pas prenable donc
toujours pas beaucoup de coups un tour
des 3 - ici c'est donc le maintenant il
ya déjà deux pions plus d'âme et
cavaliers leroy qui sait toujours pas où
il va
là c'est vraiment désespérée donc c'est
en fait le double a continué par inertie
cause houle soit en manque de temps ici
parce que c'est un joueur qui réfléchit
beaucoup dans l'ouverture et milieu de
partie
c'est bien possible que ce moment là il
ya ce qu'on appelle les électeurs à mais
je pensais qu'ils continuent à préférer
jouer parce qu il reste très peu de
temps donc le kit à qui tu as autant
jouer on ne sait jamais on sait jamais
ce qui peut arriver ça coûte ils croient
pas beaucoup plus d'énergie
malgré que je vous l'avais joué contre
l'équipe de clichy avec
deux croates non deux fois lui et pour
la bosnie on avait joué contre les
bosniaques aux championnats d'europe 93
on avait perdu 4 0 mais on à rejouer
cette fois ci pour le club de clichy
contre l'équipe de sarajevo
on a même joué une troisième fois après
on avait fait trois partout et l'année
dernière on a perdu cette fois quatre et
demi un ennemi toujours avec cause houle
dans les trois équipes dont kiel qui a
marqué deux fois sur trois je crois sur
sur les trois matches je suis le seul à
avoir battu match alors qu'on a on a
déjà un précédent vainqueur de jours
j'ai perdu contre [ __ ] l'année
dernière dont le fameux match nationale
parvenue elle est je crois un peu de
coups d'ailleurs un peu de couleurs plus
avec les bleus on met alors voyons
voyons voir ce qui se passe dans l'eau
glacée la fin de la pac aux malinois à
passer rapidement sur ses derniers coups
donc cavalier ces deux échecs
donc là le roi doit continuer à partir
avant bref quatre oui à une fourchette
amusante
s'il était venu en f3 le coup cavaliers
oui oui là il faut que resteront-elles
c'est moi en fait
voilà la prochaine phase on va dire qui
a dû interrompre le cavalier atteint par
le roi fait donc ici le roi henri iv
mais ça n'empêche pas quelques uns qui
attaquent la tour des trois lots pions
f2 avec la dame cette fois un peu à la
découverte pourrait dire rien n'y
faisait et attaquer et la tourette
attaqué également
donc là on fait un petit échec tour des
huit en effet d'inertie
finalement vaut bien qu'effectivement
qu'on me dise et là le duo d'année
cavaillé redoutable première réussie du
tous activé leurs forces pour 8 donc
maintenant voilà les bleus en finisse de
chanvre le matériel et c'est vrai que
les là les familles noires pardon il
n'en a récupéré quasiment de tout le
matériel blanc en fait il ya du tour je
dois 60 force et là ils ont pris trois
pions desjardins prend f2 avec échec au
28e coup les blancs jouent le coup en
manger car au g4 hélas hélas le
l'estocade l'estocade
voilà un cas les projets 2 et les blancs
ne peuvent même pas prendre le cavalier
et faire un échange puisque sur les
changes
la dame reprendrai avec échec et la tour
serait perdu oui et là le problème c'est
que la menace émanant de coûts donc la
menace c'est de pousser ses pions h7 en
page 5
avec échec au roi le roi g4 est obligé
de venir en âge 3 et la cave a dit viens
au f4 échec et mat
donc ici menace imparable d'autant plus
que déjà même au niveau matériel c'est
désespéré au niveau positionnelle saleh
également donc un abandon logique a
maintenant logique en tout cas un
redoutable dans mes cavaliers remarquer
les blancs jamais joué ni le retour ni
leur fou sur les droits humains ff1
n'ont pas bougé alors qu'on a les pions
et sparrow ici et ici on dise pas oui
non plus en revanche désolé pour le
remarquer sur 29 coup ils ont doublé le
roi d'une dizaine de fois non j'exagère
est aussi solide c'est une démonstration
de l'activité vraiment contrôler en fait
contre contre le matériel en fait on a
simplifié une pièce d'obtenir une
réalité très forte faut savoir après que
dame et cavalli sons sont très très fort
c'est surtout les dangers d'un roi au
centre qui sont illustrés d'un généreux
centre droit il restait au centre et
s'est retrouvé en quart du alors c'était
le tournoi ça c'était une partie du
tournoi porto rozes du mali et loi donc
en slovénie est organique et nous
importante dans l'histoire des échecs
puisque nico a dit farhan saisie
remarqué dans l'émission qui a eu un ou
plusieurs interviews nous taraude je
crois dont un avec fisher oui en 58
parait-il
oui à zéro donc le jeune jan fischer qui
avait qu'avec 15 ans en 58 il doit avoir
un peu plus 17 ou 18 17 au 18 ans et
qu'y jouer contre les russes pour se
qualifier pour le championnat il n'avait
pas réussi
il a réussi seulement quand soixante dix
il a fallu qu il attendre très longtemps
donc on rappelle mercredi sur france
inter 13h30 une super émission sur le
sacre sur le 3 septembre 1972 au sacre
sur ce vol le sacre du génial bobby
fischer celui qui a marqué les échecs
avant kasparov surtout qui a donné le
goût du jeu plein de gens oui oui
populariser le jeu en occident puisqu'en
fait ouais on n'a pas encore de champion
du monde occidental depuis depuis très
longtemps aussi
fischer est ce parce qu'il a des quines
oui ils sont français d'adoption
oui donc voilà l'actualité donc je vous
rappelle je vous rappelle que c'est le
match contre judit polgar de même vous
nous envoyez des mails et puis on vous
inscrire pour ce match sur internet
contre la meilleure joueuse du monde sur
goa voilà vous pouvez nous envoyer vos
demandes et il ya cinq places réservées
pour les internautes via diagonale donc
n'hésitez pas à nous écrire pour ça
manuel donc toi tu va préparer on va
parler un peu de ton actualité tu va
préparer ce championnat de france c'est
sûr tu es qualifié
oui donc là c'est certain ce qui est un
peu moins sûr pour une loi qui doit
attendre un peu pour des raisons
diverses et variées donc tu vas tu vois
comment tu vas te préparer ses intérêts
sans doute à avoir là
ancien champion de france doit jouer ce
championnat de france donc à besançon
besançon et commande comment tu te
prépares pour ce championnat important
avec les deux très fort joueur est bien
vais regarder ma base de données et le
voir un peu les joueurs je vais
rencontrer essayer de préparer les
ouvertures c'est à dire les premiers
coups que je joue tous mes adversaires
pour faire en sorte de bien préparer
justement pour ce tour mois bon
évidemment on connaît pas encore la
couleur
non c'est pas si on va jouer avec une
telle joueurs avec les blancs ou avec
les noirs donc ça ça pose un peu
problème ce qu'il faut faire en fait
c'est regarder sur les deux couleurs
saman pour le championnat de france de
travail de préparation est très
important mais quels sont les favoris
dans les fabris et joël d'authie joie et
une backroom il ya aussi yves dorfman
est le champion en titre
un atelier vasseur qui a gagné il ya
deux ans
me jean-marc degraeve je pense qu'il va
jouer qui est un des favoris je pense
aussi et puis beaucoup des outsiders on
peut dire avec tous les grands maîtres
français maintenant david merci à nos
arnaud hauchard eloi hollange bien sûr
une vrille et quelques autres je ne
crois pas qu'il en était non je pense
qu'on n'a pas gilles miralles maintenant
bachar twitte ligne comme l'année
dernière je ne crois pas on n'a pas
encore les listes des jardins la liste
officielle quels sont tes questions des
chances par exemple contre les bisons
les deux favoris je veux dire je sais
pas je
pour moi les favoris s'est joué à
l'outil et etienne bacrot la question
des t shirts contre ces deux joueurs là
ce que tu as déjà joué contre eux quel
est ton score éventuel j'ai jamais joué
contre etienne bacrot j'ai déjà joué
contre joël lautier plusieurs fois au
moins dix fois je pense oui
pour l'instant il mène trois victoires à
une le reste on a fait des parties le
veulent et ce fut longtemps je n'ai pas
rencontré et bon j'aimerais bien le
rencontrer pour une ou deux parties d'un
championnat devront s'en remettre un peu
les choses au point pour mettre les
choses au point et je pense que sur une
ou deux parties puisque bon c'est ça
peut jouer sur deux parties aussi un
c'est un système assez spécial tout peut
arriver
donc oui il va le rappeler on l'a déjà
par les lois mais tu vas rappelé le
principe un peu spectaculaire mais c'est
bien alors cette année pour éviter les
nuls
deux conventions les nuls rapide entre
entre grands maîtres on a fait deux
poules de huit avec deux places
qualificatives dans chaque poule dire
que les deux premiers de chaque poule
vont se rencontrer le 1er de lune
je rencontre le deuxième de l'autre en
demi finale et le deuxième de lutte
contre le premier de l'autre
donc ça fait deux demi finales en deux
parties match en deux parties avec se
départageant semi rapide donc tout ça
très ce serait un peu comme un conte
monde de foot qu'il ya des poules local
de de classification de qualification et
de classification avant un classement
dans sa poule et à suite de ça des
matchs éliminatoires
on est dans un même principe de
spectacles en tête oui tout à fait c'est
vraiment les échecs spectacle l'année
dernière aux championnats de france l'a
vu beaucoup de matches nuls cette année
avec ce système là il y en aura plus
puisqu'il faut être parmi les 2 2 enfin
faites dans les deux parmi sept dire que
là on peut pas se permettre de faire des
nuls faut 2 places c'est pas beaucoup il
faut vraiment gagner des parties il faut
mettre le turbo dès le début donc ça va
encourager vraiment du spectacle des
parties combative et des partis surtout
qui se termine par un résultat en
manuels à ton avis toi quel est le
favori à part toi je sais pas si je me
plaçais ce qu'est loi est la loi et
favori par exemple ont éloigné peut pas
dire que les lois soient favoris et loi
fait partie d outsider un peu comme moi
mais je pense que les favoris logiques
sont le favori logique c'est joël
lautier lui s'il est au dessus du lot à
mon avis est ce qu etienne bacrot peut
pas y l'afp yann bacrot on peut
momon progresse d'année en année j'ai
fait un très bon et à lausanne récemment
je crois mon ces parties rapides mais
bon c'est quand même bon résultat
etienne bacrot nathalie baye et moi je
craque aussi l'oise où il va il va faire
un super résultat aussi il ya deux ans
il avait fait un très beau début et de
tournoi et il était donné en tête je
crois en même temps mais la formule a
été adapté pour moi de toute façon à
chaque fois dans les sept premières
parties j'ai toujours été pratiquement
en tête du championnat alors on peut
dire aussi si non il va signer pas
qualifiés me dire bonjour en accession
voilà je voulais en parler justement
autour de ce championnat c'est bien on
va en parler on profite d'avoir deux
qualifiés pour ce championnat il ya
évidemment autour nicolas des double
accession d open même ouvert à tout le
monde en fait il ya des lianes lors
d'une session pour se qualifier au
championnat car c'est un grand tournoi
accession ouvert à tous les joueurs qu
un classement international
et puis en dehors de ça il ya un ou deux
tournois open points de plus qu'aux
servira comme un même tournoi donc ça il
ya vraiment beaucoup de joueurs je crois
qu'il ya une voie là il ya quelque chose
qu'on a 800 joueurs qui se réunissent
les normes
c'est presque un millier de joueurs
quasiment et j'en avais la chance
d'éviter aussi et plus de 60 ans que
voilà il ya côté ça donc manuel on va
clore là dessus tu t'occupes aussi du
site
oui tu es webmaster voilà peut-être tu
peux donner l'adresse en profiter oui
l'adresse c'est http deux points dont un
double slash ce qui est d'accord c'est
le jour ce préfixe habituel oui
www.dondusang.net grec tirait échec eux
ch/cs point org
auberger voilà point org donc le club de
clichy et eut mis à jour est un petit et
de choses relatives au club aux joueurs
du club sur les tournois sûr beaucoup
beaucoup d'actualité et des parties
commentées beaucoup de parties
commentées ici c'est aussi bien par tous
les grands maîtres et
efforts joueurs du club de clichy et on
peut te contacte et envoyer des mails
bien sûr et tu réponds sans problème
voilà voilà donc un grand maître
informaticiens aussi
voilà donc on va quitter l'as et doit
cette émission je crois que tu donc tu
nous rejoigne plus pour les prochaines
semaines puisque tu vas t'entraîner
voyous il avait été déclaré pour moi
les théoriciens tourner un film plein de
paris en plein de france
nicolas giffard la semaine prochaine oui
je serai encore là je serai encore là et
on t'appellera évidemment avec grand
plaisir manuel bonne chance pour la
suite et à très bientôt d'un diagonale
et pourquoi pas si on filme championnat
de france et des petites interviews à
chaud après sa victoire sur joël lautier
donc voilà je vous dis au revoir bien
sûr la semaine prochaine n'oubliez pas
que la semaine prochaine diagonale c'est
aussi diagonale un espagnol à 20h à 21h
ces diagonales en français et demain le
match contre judit polgar on a des
passes à vous donner vous nous envoyez
un mail voilà je vous dis à la semaine
prochaine au revoir bientôt
il